this is worth it QA marking dois hard
dois Paul Oh welcome to another worth it
Q and a first of all it's so much fun
we decided to do together if you are
watching this you probably just recently
watched our sandwich episode maybe so
that's why we're going to again be
eating sandwiches okay
no chance can't fill the chairs we're
doing this to celebrate the end of a
successful season five rape vlog we
asked you guys to ask us questions on
Instagram we have an Instagram you can
follow us on the off season and Buzz
people are this sandwiches first yes oh
it's cold all right well you popped it
up and I'll get with the first question
here we go hey Angela what are the most
memorable habit you noticed from each
other so you usually doesn't make it in
the video but Steven will often oh say
can I just say before he says something
right can I just say I'm just say could
I just say but that's a little behind
the curtain that you might not know
about which this one is in front of the
party and you are strangely extremely
strategic with the way that you evil you
would make a good chef mmm you make the
cookie now and I'll read one okay from
NK harissa are you guys planning on
another season
I know season five is not over but
cannot control the excitement for
another season in the making it's what
we made this in the middle of this
season so yes
Vaughn TN Swan D is relleno a part of
the hashtag worth it team everybody who
works on worth it is part of the hashtag
worth it - yeah I think all the viewers
are part of the hashtag we're the team -
hey hey you're all part of the hashtag
worth of team an Ice Cream Sandwich is
worth it wherever her skills and
perspective are appropriate we'll be
happy to have her back out sandwich time
Cheers
I don't want to get your ice cream on my
sandal it's the same ice cream that's
right are you the best thing I'm a small
bit yeah you got greedy good ice cream
well is it good next question you ready
demon what type of music do you guys
like parentheses including animals I can
answer for you classical music or opera
or anything before 1900s before you were
born
yeah classical music for me I like
really chill laid-back music favorite
composer nobody yeah probably Bach takes
the cake
I like stuff that will make me feel good
Adam very Adam answer yeah hey what's up
oh yeah welcome to LA oh yeah thank you
that's right I asked you it was the best
in you in Japan so much Jeff office mmm
wasn't it amazing uh or fate Part A Part
A the matcha is so smooth here what was
the best thing you ate the cold soup
came in at a furry everything was the
tongue stew at kegg omurice
you're just saying that cuz you lucky
chica chick walks
tackles to take you to the number one
this is the number one day yeah oval
eyes famous number
remember face number one yeah what did
we call him TG kiki drew oh geez you
drew Adam what's your favorite yeah and
then Adam died my mum's Cemal what
country would you guys be interested in
going to and what would you want to try
there it's not my Christian no you're
gonna answer that where would you go if
you say it then we have to take you yeah
oh is it yeah but I want the bed numb
hello I don't want to eat a lot of the
street food mm-hmm
where'd you go Paris that gets I just
want it's a bread up I really want to go
to Brazil and maybe do fruit cuz there's
a lot of fruits in Brazil that don't
exist here mmm
imagine tasting something you've never
tasted before all right thanks for
joining us yeah thank you I'll see you
in a bit yeah bye-bye
okay so Adam just asked me if I could
taste brian brian berger oh yes there
were a few unsolved questions about
crossovers and what do I think about him
on Twitter and my texted him actually
free he said not the moment I said why
not I said I'm looking for ghouls that
is literally what it says that's a
hundred percent the last text was just
I'm looking for goals from Pyu Sarah I
don't have a question I just love you
guys I just want this with that well
it's not a question Sarah so write
harder next time
next question broseph underscore Vaughn
underscore bro
longtime followers since the beginning
has been an interesting to see the
evolution of how you are all
experiencing when describing the food
you are reviewing I'll have your palette
and your personal food preferences
evolve as a result of this show has your
regular meal rotation changed
significantly what about your restaurant
orders I eat at Subway a lot less I am
now always looking for local places
willing to try stuff that I have
walk into our herd of the floor I've
become way more obsessed with trying to
find unique and great ingredients to
cook with at home one time I was buying
eggs at the farmers market and the girl
was like oh my god you're the guy from
that show I'm gonna tell people that
that guy eats my eggs and I was like
hell yeah that's the best compliment
I've ever got there were sick eggs
Alicia I died Nicole how do you pay for
the cost of the meals does must be paid
or do the restaurants pay for the
publicity we always offer to pay for
everything this is a show it has a
budget and also the question is do we
get sponsored by restaurant see you know
and we go to restaurants that we decide
our worth it to go to not restaurants
that are reaching out to us a try or
like well we don't go because it's free
to go that's never the case yeah yeah
exactly
okay there you go oh one one with me I
also got Adam a cinnamon roll because as
you know I owe him 1000 I have already
paid off one now feed off to crayon 1209
does Adam really speak less in real life
or is it just as personnel or is it just
his personality I think you wanted to
say for the series also could you do a
country specific episode with the most
iconic dishes a Vika okay no - first
we're gonna answer the first part okay
wow you are laying down the law with the
questions and the cameras are not
rolling he is the most talkative of the
bunch once we get into the car on the
train in the airplane it's Queen chromey
inquires why did Stephen move to New
York City also after all these years did
Andrew finally got himself a cat cuz he
should okay okay he's a perfect creepy
cat dude hold up you just said no to
furs and you asked the twofer Jesse
could talk about your cat that's true
you know the Big Apple was calling me by
name so I was like I gotta go I'm
spider-man
really here answer well so actually my
brother lives in Connecticut his fiancee
lives in Brooklyn so it's nice to be
near to family also within the bus for
you I wanted to experience different
parts of the company and in New York
they're doing more of editorial work
sales work okay answer your question
yeah I got a cat it's awesome wanna see
a pic Oh
last question a Nina mas are you guys
going to cover Ukrainian food or Andrew
since you guys is that great with an
eight-episode on malaysian food for
Steven yeah there's a lot of great
Ukrainian food in New York City when it
fits into an episode for sure and that's
a Hyuna hey that was all the questions
there were over a thousand questions so
I don't think we can get to all of them
you have a few quick announcements
announcement number one check out our
merch it's now exclusively on Amazon
heyyo amazon.com / BuzzFeed worth it no
check it out right here right there and
we have a brand new shirt did you see
our egg video if you did you might
recognize this eggs back graphic I think
it makes a swell of shirt do you like
that video like I did maybe you like
this shirt
her
like that I'm gonna go my majesty also
we do want to say a quick thank you
because we were nominated for a street
did we win one of those last year we did
nice let's hang on that and thank you to
everyone behind the scenes who makes
this show possible last but not least
what's next for us I'm worth it
we've got some new worth it one stops
that the new theme song that show
spin-off where we go to one location and
find something cool like the grapes like
that seafood restaurant you might have
seen me holding a sword on my Instagram
that's right I have an Instagram you
know what's that a shameless self plug
I'll put in the video yeah
how does it feel looking in the mirror
alright
yeah those are all the A's bye
[Music]
oh oh yes